[Music]
in 2006 I fell in love with Z and I told
my brother hey we should do the same
thing I way I thought he was crazy but
each day to be he'd say Hank
[Music]
dftba Oh goodbye Brotherhood 2.0 we know
it will be sad to see go
will you miss us if we know from my
pants will you do your happy dance
took over and Chris Crocker cried
Tay Zonday sayin lonely girl died in a
year with some guy said don't tase me
bro
we took that row and we added 2.0 whoa
goodbye Brotherhood 2.0 we don't know
that should be census he'd go
every time we think about my pants it
makes us do our happy dance
blend it feels and shirtless pics and
wax in my chin no more we never have to
do that crap again do you think we're
closer now we were last year John we're
doing a duet I think that's abundantly
clear Oh goodbye Brotherhood 2.0
we know that you'll be sad to see and go
I don't ever think we'll leave from my
pants so you can do your happy dance
yeah you can do your happy dance a funny
thing we realized while we wrote this
song it's bit about more than us all
awesome people got together to do
awesome things and last one it makes us
so Santa single goodbye Brotherhood to
fall
we know that you'll be sad to see Andrew
we won't ever leave my pants so you can
do your happy dance and though it is
true that our project is ending the
rules it seems may need some amending
you all we must say John and hey cleaner
are here to say oh hello to whatever
comes next
here's to a thousand more secret
projects we fell in love with
nerdfighting and couldn't let it go
so to 2080 say hello
that one really good John until the end
of where I like hit my thumb really hard
on the e-string and how do you have
anything to say to their and fighters
while I'm sucking my wound nerdfighters
you're the best and I don't mean that
figuratively it's been fantastic
we'll see you weekly in January
to 2008 we say hello and I promise no
matter what happens next year I'll never
sing again go
you